Kan du förstå att det låter lite skumt för folk som aldrig har sysslat med kampsport?
Vi har tränat i ett halvår för att slå på varandra.
Sen så går jag in och tänker att vi har väl inget ortalt, vi ska bara knocka varandra en stund.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi en lite speciell gäst till podden, det är Andreas Gustavsson som inte är entreprenör på det här sättet som jag brukar intervjua, utan det här är en UFC-fighter, så det är lite annorlunda upplägg.
Välkommen till podden, Andreas.
Tack så mycket.
Inom entreprenörsvärlden så är det ju väldigt sådär hajpat att, ah, disciplin och du måste orka möta smärtor och det kommer att vara tufft att göra ont.
Om du lyssnar på det kan du känna ett visst förrakt för det där och bara, det där gör ju inte ont.
Jag kan väl egentligen förstå att det blir väl på sätt och vis samma sak, men...
Nej, nej man behöver inte vara snäll i den här podden.
Det är inte alls samma sak.
Nej, nej alltså det gör väl så klart inte ont kanske.
Mer vad det gör hos mig men vi alla fliter ju på så olika vis.
Men jag skulle väl säga att det gör mer ont med det jag håller på med i alla fall.
För de som inte vet vad UFC är, jag säger det snarare än MMA för det känns nästan som att UFC är nästan mer etablerat än vad MMA är.
Men vad är det egentligen du sysslar med?
Vad är din sport?
Det är ju MMA, alltså Mixed Martial Art.
Det är alla kampsporter i ett.
Det fina med det här är att du kan komma från brottning, boxning, judo, karate, allt möjligt och kombinera det.
Alla kommer från olika bakgrunder.
Jag kommer från brottningen och någon kommer från boxningen.
Hur man sedan väljer att sätta ihop det där i ett fullt slagsmål, ger det till sporten som den är.
Det är ett kontrollerat slagsmål med olika färdigheter från hela världen.
Jag tänker att det som ska bli lite kul här idag är att vi ska liksom inte hamna för mycket i träning, utan vi ska snarare hamna i hela mindsetet bakom och hur man bibehåller ett lugn samtidigt som någon sparkar in i magen.
Det är ändå en fascinerande vinkel för någon som inte brukar göra det på daglig basis.
Men innan vi går vidare där, du säger att du är från brottningen och du säger att i MMA kan man sätta ihop alltihop, men är det inte så att alla mästare kommer från brottningen?
Hur många karate...
det finns väl en som har kommit från karate?
Ja, precis, men det är ju som sagt vanligast att de som går längst kommer från brottningen.
Allt är en grekromersk brottning eller fristilsbrottning.
Å andra sidan, enligt mig så är ju det den bästa grunden för just det här.
Du kommer i princip alltid in i närakamp.
Och där är ju brottarna bäst.
Vad är det som gör att för oss som är lite nördiga och kollade på UFC back in the day när BJ var liksom the shit.
Vad är det som gör att brottning har tagit över?
Jag tror att det alltså, idrottskvinnor utvecklas ju hela tiden och man toppar varandra hela tiden.
Det känns ju som att snart finns det inget stopp på hur pass fysiskt man kan vara.
Men jag tror ändå att skillnaden där mellan brottare och icke-brottare är just att du har den absolut bästa fysiken.
Det finns ingen annan sport i världen som kan konkurrera med just den allsidiga fysiken.
Visst, men jag brukar referera till skidåkare till exempel.
De har ju ofta en extrem uthållighet och koalition.
Men det är ju bara i längdskidspåret, inte bara men oftast har brottarna allt när det kommer perifysiska.
Och jag tror det är det som gör att man kan leva så länge på att vara brottare i den här sporten.
För i slutändan så är det fysiken som spelar roll ändå.
Trots att man möter någon som är otroligt överlägset tekniskt så skulle jag kunna hålla i den personen i en kvack och trötta ut den.
Så att han inte har någon mytta av sin teknik.
Bara för att jag orkar med att jag är starkare.
Är det så, är det så din vad ska man säga, din gameplan här, går du in och så håller du fast dem och så viskar du liksom i öra till dem att det är lugnt, jag är inte ens trött än.
Exakt, exakt, vad har jag sagt så har jag gjort.
Har du också de här gamla brottningsgrejerna för dig, du vet att man inte duschar en vecka innan.
Nej, alltså för fan är det äckligt.
Vi, speciellt Finland var ju sådär.
Du vet vi var ju på träningsläger i Finland med brottningen och du vet de duschar ju inte på hela träningslägen.
Och de använder samma jävla t-shirt varje pass.
Och vi tränade tre pass om dagen i en vecka.
Du vet den där t-shirten stod ju rakt ut när man höll han liksom.
Och är för fan, de luktade riktigt äckligt.
Jag tror det där var någon sykning de höll på med.
Men jag tillhör inte den kategorin i alla fall.
Jag duschar i alla fall en gång i veckan.
Jag tänkte också på, är det positivt eller, om man nu inte har sett dig, så får man väl gå in och googla dig lite grann.
Du ser ju inte ut som en pretty boy.
Om jag ska gå i en gränd med någon, så tar jag gärna med dig som sällskap.
Jag känner mig trygg, du ser lite arg ut liksom.
Är det positivt att se farlig ut?
Eller vill man hellre se ut som en snäll pojke så att folk underskattar en?
Ja, jag kan nog tycka att det kan vara positivt.
Det kan ju, har man en målståndare som kanske är lite svajig i cyket, där det går lite upp och ner, så kan det ju sätta lite griller i hugget på den man möter.
Han ser farlig ut.
Jag vet ju själv hur jag kan tänka om jag möter någon som fan den här ser vass ut, den här ser, han ser lite farlig ut.
Och det blir, även om man inte är, även om man inte skapar rädsla, så blir det ändå ett tankesätt som blir lite negativt.
Så i den aspekt kan det ju vara att det sätter lite griller i hugget på sina målståndare.
Är det därför man har, nu var ju detta länge sedan jag körde, men du har ju rejäla blomkålsöron.
Är det äkta blomkålsöron eller gjorde du som vissa sådana här som ställde sig och så lät de folk, slår de på öronen för att se ut som brottare?
Det här är helt äkta öron.
Jag har förtjänat dem.
Exakt, jag har förtjänat dem till 100 procent.
Det vet jag ju att man tänkte alltid på det när man skulle möta någon i SV som jag körde, då såg man ju, ifall de hade ordentliga öron, då visste man att fan, jag kommer att förlora den här matchen.
Ja, precis, precis.
Ja, det finns ju vissa som har gjort dem det själva, eftersom att det ska se coolt ut.
Exakt.
Och det är fan, viktigt löjligt.
Hehehe, ja vi hade några på klubben faktiskt.
Jag tänkte, kan du inte ta oss med hur du hamnade i kampsport, och det är ju ofta inte det man börjar med, utan ofta fastnar man ju i fotboll när man är liten, och så kör man lite inneband.
Kampsport är ju fortfarande, även om det är jätteetablerat nu, så är det ju fortfarande lite halv-obskyr sport som många föräldrar kanske inte vill sätta sina barn i.
Hur hamnade du i brottningen och sedan MMA?
Det började med att jag, som alla andra barn, jag velade börja med karate, judo, det tyckte man ju var häftigt.
Men när det var dags, där vi var 6-7 års ålder, min far tyckte inte alls att jag skulle börja med judo eller karate eller någon sport där man slåss.
Så han tog mig till brottamattan där vi var 6-7 års ålder och jag var fast på en gång.
Jag var som klippt och skuret förr.
Jag var ganska stor som liten och jag kunde utnyttja min styrka så det passade mig bra.
Jag tyckte det var otroligt kul.
Jag hängde kvar i brottningen och utvecklades bra och jag höll väl på fram till...
Jag var kanske 20...
26-27 med brottning och vanlig grek-rombörsk-brottning.
Och tog ett par mästerskaosmedaljer i SM, Nogilska, något EM-brons.
Jag gick aldrig riktigt hela vägen i brottningen.
Det var där de kanske tre sista åren som jag bara stod och stampade på samma plats.
Jag utvecklades inte och så hade väl gnistan liksom slocknad lite grann.
Så jag tog väl ett beslut där att jag provar någonting annat.
Jag kliver ifrån brottningen och så testar jag lite summation wrestling.
Där är övergången från brottningen då.
Det var jättekul.
Jag började väl, när jag började känna mig trygg i summation wrestling, så började jag väl utveckla det där till shootfighting.
En mild variant av MMA.
Hur roligt var det för dina motståndare där i din första shootfighting match när det stod att du hade ett års erfarenhet inom shootfighting och de hade ett och ett halvt och så kommer du in och så...
Ofta får man ju se sin motståndare och säga de har gått noll i matchen, det är lugnt.
De är på samma nivå som mig, jag ska bara färgan också.
Ja, jag tror mina motståndare fick en chock för jag hade ju ändå kanske 400 bråttomatcher i ryggsäcken.
Så jag var ju så vagn där.
Jag hade ju tävlat i 25 år redan, så det var ju inget konstigt för mig.
Men jag dansade ju igenom hela amatörer.
Amatörer, MMA, shoot fighting, det finns ju många termer, A-klass, B-klass.
Jag höll väl på kanske och tävlade aktivt i amatörer i två år kanske.
Nej, kanske bara ett år till och med.
Sen klivde jag över på props, för det var liksom jag var för bra för amatörer.
Ni är inte schysst eller?
Nej, med tanke på min bakgrund.
Vissa börjar ju direkt med MMA.
Ja, det kanske är jag får möta någon som håller på ett år och har inte någon bakgrund inom någon annan kampsport.
Så jag tog ett SM-guld först i amatören MMA, sen åkte jag på VN och tog ett silver där i amatör VN.
Jag förlorade finalen mot Ryss väldigt jämnt.
Men sen efter det kläder jag på proffs då.
Det gick väl bra där också.
Jag vann mina fem första proffsmatcher.
Jag tror jag gick fem matcher i första året.
Men fick du tillbaks gnistan där då eller var det helt plötsligt var det nya grejer att lära sig eller vad var det som gjorde att nu orkar jag börja om?
Det var väl det, man fick ändra om träningen.
Lite grann träna på ett annat sätt.
Det är såklart att gnistan kom tillbaka.
Nu fick jag helt plötsligt börja lära mig att vuxas, brottas på ett annat sätt, hitta andra grejer som passar mig.
Det blev inte så enformigt som brottningen kändes då.
Så det blev en ny timing.
Plus att det gick bra också.
Sen märkte jag att man kan tjäna pengar på också.
Då vart det ännu roligare.
Att man kan få lite sponsorer.
Men det är klart, pengar är en oro.
Och att det går bra.
Vad tjänade du där på dina första fem krossmassor?
Det var inte många.
Det är ett cyoprotein.
Ja, det var ju så är det ju.
Redde du på den tiden när man fortfarande fick, det var inte längesen, fick du liksom, här får du fem biljetter som du får sälja och du får vinsten?
Ja, lite så faktiskt.
Men det var ju ändå roligt då, när man kommer från brottningen, där får man inte skit.
Ja, det får äran men du får ingenting annat.
Så det var ju ändå ett steg upp.
Det var ett steg upp, ja absolut.
Ja, men där är vi nu.
Sedan har jag ju, här var det på.
Det gick bättre och bättre och bättre.
Min första förlust fick jag mot en brottare faktiskt, i Polen.
Han var ju en duktig brottare.
Jag hade koll på han innan också.
Han tävlade alltid i en vikslash över mig.
Och han tog faktiskt brons i OS i brottning.
Jag och mitt tränare säger att vi blev rånad på den matchen.
För jag gjorde en bättre match.
Men vi var i Polen, det var polska domare.
Han var en polsk stjärna.
Vi gick till domslut.
Domarna dömde till hans fördel.
Som flak.
Men det är skitsamma.
Sen jag tog den förlusten lite högt tror jag.
För jag la av efter det.
Jag tog två års uppehåll.
När du säger uppehåll, vad innebär uppehåll då?
Jag och Kev inte upp på en kampspårsmatta på två år.
Oj, ingen träning, ingenting?
Bara styrkigt träning.
Jag vet inte riktigt vad som hände där.
Vi hade kött hus, jag höll på att renovera, snickra.
Vi skaffade barn.
Man tror att man blir lite vuxen och klok.
Vad ska jag hålla på med det här för när jag har barn?
Så jag gick där hemma i två år och tänkte att det var tråkigt det här.
Jag har tävlat hela mitt liv och nu finns det ingenting.
Vem vart jag nu?
Nu vart jag bara pappa Andreas istället.
Det var jättebra det också såklart, men det var någonting som fattades ganska rejält.
Det sålde min fru också.
Efter två år där så tog jag en diskussion med min fru.
Jag vill tillbaka.
Jag vill göra ett försök att komma till UFC, den största i världen.
Hon sa kör, du måste göra din dröm.
För lite där är vi.
Jag kom tillbaka.
Vägen tillbaka var lång.
Jag tänkte säga, var var det för dig?
Du sa att du gick några proffsmatcher där.
När du har varit, när du har tatt ditt uppboll här och du ska ge dig tillbaka och du säger att jag ska gå till UFC.
Det har man ju hört extra människor säga.
För alla som inte vet så är det Champions League, eller den stora galan eller tävlingen.
Men hur långt ifrån var du det när du fick sätta igång igen och börja harva?
Jag var nog ganska långt därifrån, men när jag började tävla proffs så var jag en av de mest aktiva fighterna i Sverige.
Jag gick så mycket matcher på kort tid, så det var bara att fortsätta på det spåret.
Jag tror det året jag klemde tillbaka var 20-22 tror jag.
När jag kände mig huvudsak på det, då gick jag väl en fem matcher till tror jag samma år.
Då var jag väl, jag tror jag radade upp fem vinster i rad då också.
Men då var det ju liksom att, nu kanske det inte är så långt kvar.
Vi hade lite kontakt med UFC, delas matchmaker och de var intresserade, men de velade se lite mer.
Vi gick någon match till.
Och till slut fick vi chansen att tävla i Dana White content seriens.
Så där man tävlar i UFC-kontrakten.
Ja men vi packade väskan och åkte till Las Vegas.
Hur funkar det där?
Är det så här, ja du har en chans på dig, nu får du leverera här.
Hur bygger man upp hjärnan för det?
Är det här eller får jag vänta i tre år till?
Jag åkte dit och tänkte att fan, vinna inte nu.
Låt oss titta på en skitbra uppladdning.
Ja men jag åkte dit och tänkte att fan, hoppas jag inte vinner.
Jag var fortfarande i det stadiet att ska jag hålla på med det här.
Varför gör jag det här?
Jag har alltid frågorna i skallen.
Fan jag är sliten, jag är trött.
Så det har varit lite så här, det är klart att jag varit jävligt glad att jag vann, men samtidigt så var jag såhär, nu är jag ju fast här.
Så det var lite såhär belade känslor att ja, nu är det ju bara att köra på ett tag till.
Ja, och där är vi idag.
Men du har ju också fått gå din första UFC match.
Ja, precis.
Och där vann du ju.
Ja men precis, precis.
Det var inte lika stryligt där, vi var många avhopp, många avbokningar.
Vi åkte ut i, vi skulle ju gå där med Las Vegas igen då, på vägen ner, drog sig.
Hur är det att gå UFC match i Las Vegas jämfört med att gå SM här i Sverige i Shoot Fighting?
Hur är publiktrycket?
Det är ju en stor skillnad såklart.
Det är lite tråkig svensk scen.
Det är inte så stort intresse.
Vi får vara nöjliga om vi fyller en arena med 2-3 tusen.
Om man känner helst den.
Ja, exakt.
Men till att ha sist, min senaste match där det var 30 tusen på läktaren.
Jag vet inte, jag är väl den som brukar stänga av.
Jag hör inte publiken, jag ser inte publiken.
Inte så mycket i alla fall.
Det är klart att man har uppmärksammat det.
Snarare så blir man väl lite mer pepp.
Det är en häftig upplevelse.
Man är ju en så liten bur i mitten av det äldre folkhavet.
Det är häftigt.
Samtidigt spelar det ingen roll.
Jag hade kunnat gå den UFC-matchen här hemma i Bollnäs i ett litet garage.
Det hade inte spelat mig någon roll.
Är du så här lugn när du går matchen eller blir du aggressivt pett?
För nu låter du nästan, jag säger inte att du låter uttråkad av att slåss, men det känns liksom som en dag på jobbet.
Det har vi ju vid det.
Det är ett ganska monotontråkigt arbete jag har, anser jag.
Det är liksom, jag vaknar.
Vad ska jag göra idag?
Ja, jag ska träna tretas och så ska jag äta.
Det är ju ett pissliv.
Alltså egentligen, du tränar sönder kroppen för lite pengar.
Vad är det som gör att du ändå fortsätter då?
Det är det enda som gör det värt, det är ju när du står där i buren och har budgetmatchen.
De få minuterna av eufori, och det är ju en form av drog.
Det kan man jämföra med.
Nu har jag inte testat något drog eller så, men jag kan bara tänka mig att det är samma kit man fått.
För den kicken går inte att beskriva.
Det är en häftig känsla.
Du har liksom haft två, tre månader innan matchen av ett helvete slet.
Du har bantat, du har gått på diet i tre månader.
Du har offrat allt det goda i livet.
Du har gått och varit sur, grenig.
Du har pressat din kropp till det yttersta.
Och just när den pressen och stressen släpper dig från kroppen, så är de som befriar sig.
Det är lite det som gör det värt det, på något konstigt vis.
Det är lite självplågeri men ändå skördar frukten när man väl har vunnit och känner sig jävligt nöjd.
Men jag kan inte säga att det är en rolig resa man gör.
Men ändå valde du att ta ett steg tillbaka och sen komma tillbaka.
Handlade det om den här, framförallt identitetsgrejen, att fan, jag är ju en fighter, vad gör jag om jag inte fightas?
Ja men lite så.
Det vart ju såklart en identitetskris där om att gå våren.
Försökte jag bli tyngdlyftad istället.
Jag gick upp jättemycket i vikt, jag vägde över 100 kilo, drog nästan 300 kilo marklyft och bara körde tungt.
Men jag vart ju stark som ett as.
Men det var ändå inte jag.
Jag kände väl att jag gjorde för att stå där i buren, eller buren, mattan och tävla mot en annan man.
Inte för den delen att jag tycker om att slåss.
Jag hatar att slåss.
Varför ska man slåss egentligen?
Men när jag kommer in i buren, då blir jag en helt annan person och tycker att det är svinnkul att slåss.
Att kunna erövra en annan man.
Och fan jag är bättre än dig.
Du kunde inte slå ner mig, jag slåg ner dig.
Det känns så här häftigt.
Det tar nog igen tillbaka till många hundratusen år.
Hur vi var gjord förr i tiden på vikingatiden, för stenolden, hur vi överlevde.
Vi har ju den där jakt och kamp i våra kroppar i genetiken.
Så det är väl den som kommer fram lite grann att kunna leva ut.
Jag tror att det är lite svårt att förstå om man inte har kört just kampsport.
För jag upplever, jag har också kört fotboll, du vet, som alla människor, hur jag har kört inneband i volleboll, alla de här jävla sporterna som man ska köra.
Jag började inte med kampsport förrän jag var lite äldre.
Jag var nog 25, nej 20 kanske, någonstans där i alla fall.
När man kom in i kampsport så var det såhär, ja, det här tycker jag, eller det här känner jag igen, eller min kropp vill göra det här typ, och att göra, för det du pratar om är lite typ dominanskänslan att känna, fan jag kan liksom äga den här situationen och dominera den här situationen och göra lite vad jag själv tänker att jag ska göra.
Och det är någonting som man inte riktigt får prata om, för det låter lite alls suspekt.
Men det är en känsla som är jävligt häftig och jag tror att om man inte väl har kört ett kampmoment och kört den så låter det bara såhär, fan det låter halvpervärst ju.
Det är inte så att man går igång på känslan, men det är en väldigt skön typ dopaminkick eller det är någonting som bara, fan det här är kul liksom.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nej, men jag håller med.
Det är ju just kamp person mot person.
Jag tror, jag tror, det känns ändå som AP börjar komma mer och mer, bland kvinnor också.
Och det är ju, fan, titta förr liksom, på romatiden.
Varför hade man olympiska spelen med, ja med gladiatorerna.
Alltså folk har alltid älskat våld.
Det är ju någonting som lockar i princip varje människa att se våld.
Då görs skräckfilmer, actionfilmer.
Det kan ju inte bara vara en slump att det finns våld, för det ligger i vår natur, i människans natur.
Kan du tycka att det är lite halv weird att säga att vi inte hade haft tillåten Kampsport nu och jag skulle lägga fram ett lagförslag där jag säger jag tycker att det är okej att vi sätter två människor i en bue och så låter vi dem slå varandra och försöka bryta.
Och det är helt tillåtet att de bryter varandras armar eller okben eller vad som helst.
Och vi betalar för att titta på det och vi får dessutom satsa pengar på det.
Det hade ju varit ganska svårt att driva igenom det lagförslaget.
Ja det tror jag, absolut, absolut men...
Nej men man får inte armbåga på det sättet.
Men det sättet är okej och då är det okej.
Då är det lugnt, då är det lugnt.
Nu får vi faktiskt armbågas på...
Ah okej får man göra 26 eller vad man ska säga.
Ja giv mig något, nu har de ämnat det och det tycker jag är bra.
Ja.
Ja men va fan varför ska man ha regeln?
Det var det sista godkända alltså.
Nej men jag tänkte ändå varför ska det vara så mycket regler när man ska in i en bue och slåss?
Jag kan förstå att vi rycker hår och bitar, det ska man väl inte göra men allt annat borde vara tillåtet.
Men känner du rädsla när du går in och ska slåss?
Eller känner du rädsla inför?
Det är lite, jag vet inte om, jag tror inte att det är rädsla.
Det tror jag inte, då skulle jag inte hålla på med det här.
Du är lite osäker.
Nej, inte osäker heller men det är mer en typ av nervositet.
En form av förväntansångest kan man säga.
Men jag tror den är ganska bra att ha.
Du håller dig lite spänn, förväntan.
Du är inte avslappnad.
Du vet inte hur den här motståndaren står framför dig.
Vad kommer han göra?
Hur stark är han?
Hur teknisk är han?
Du har självklart kollat upp honom innan du möter honom, men du kan aldrig veta vad som kommer att hända.
Det är väl lite den känslan som är konstig på något sätt.
Inte olustig, men det är en typ av förväntan som gör att du blir lite nervös.
Men jag tror, som jag sa, det är också bra.
Kliver man in i en match, det har jag gjort också, där man känner att det är lugnt, det är inga problem alls.
Det här behöver inte ens värma upp.
Så blir det oftast inte så bra.
Du får avslappna, du är inte med.
Det är en form av underskattning.
Och det är livsfarligt att underskatta någon man ska slås mot.
Jag kan gå in och möta en helt ny amatör och bli knockad.
Spela ingen roll hur bra jag är.
Det handlar ju också om att kunna träffa och inte bli träffad.
Går jag in och är jävligt avslappnad och har underskattat min motståndare så slappnar jag av på ett helt annat sätt.
Kanske jag åker på en smäll och bara somnar.
Hur gör du för att få till...
Nu återigen, bara så att folk förstår att jag pratar inte om MMA när jag pratar om mig själv, jag pratar om submission wrestling och det är i princip att man kramas jämfört med MMA då där man slår på varandra.
Så vi sätter det i perspektiv.
Ja, precis.
Men jag kunde ju typ aldrig tända till det.
Jag har ju ingen...
Jag orkar ju typ inte bry mig.
Eller det är såhär, jag ska tävla och så är jag nästan på träning och då...
Jag fick inte till den här...
Medan vissa människor är ju nästan sämst på träning och sen i match så blir det som att de slår på ett extra nivå och helt plötsligt kan de bara vinna.
Har du något sätt för att komma in i liksom rätt mindset av att nu ska jag liksom agera?
Men jag är inte en av dem heller som spelar ut och försöker ägga upp mig själv.
Jag tror jag är mer lik dig där, att jag håller mig så jävla lugn.
Jag har aldrig gått in i en match och varit arg eller förbannad.
Lossas vara arg och skriker och härjar.
Man ser hur många håller på att ägga upp sig själv.
Många kanske försöker vara arg för att kunna slåss.
Jag är inte så.
Jag går hellre in i buren och är lugn.
Jag skulle säga att jag får en bättre match om jag skulle möta en polare på andra sidan.
Jag vet att jag kommer slå huvud av den där killen och att vi är kompisar.
Jag ser det som en idrott, jag har ingenting otalt med han som står på andra sidan.
Jag tycker inte illa om han.
Han står bara i vägen för mig för att vinna den här matchen.
Det är inget illa menat mot han.
Men jag behöver inte vara arg för det.
Jag slåss bättre om jag är avslappnad och inte, tror jag.
Jag har aldrig varit arg i en match.
Jag slåss bättre om jag är lugn.
Det låter ju väldigt charmigt att spöa på någon men ändå, ändå, på ett avslappnat sätt.
Ja, absolut.
Kan du förstå att det låter lite skumt för folk som aldrig har sysslat med kampsport?
Att vi har tränat i ett halvår för att slå på varandra.
Och sen så går jag in och tänker, vi har väl inget ortalt, vi ska bara knocka varandra en stund.
Ja, nej men det låter så här jättekonstigt.
Absolut.
Det är klart att jag går inte in och avslappnar, man är laddad, man är liksom på gång.
Men just det här med ilska, det är ganska vanligt i fightningen att folk försöker bygga upp en ilska mot sina motståndare, innan matcherna.
Jag vet inte om det beror på en osäkerhet, en nervositet som slår över.
Man ser hur de står i städansen och puttas och skriker åt varandra.
Visst, nu kan det ha varit mycket skit stack innan, från båda sålder man har sagt att man ska göra, men det är med vänns morsa och du vet hur snacken kan gå.
Då kan man väl bli arg.
Jag tror att de som spelar det över och skriker och härjar har lite sämre cykel än de som försöker hålla sig ödmjuk och lugn.
Tror jag faktiskt.
Du nämnde en grej som är jävligt knickande där tidigt.
Det var att inför första UFC-matchen så bokade de om datum några gånger.
Ja, precis.
Hur tätt in på och bokade de om datum och hur påverkar det hela ens camp och inställning.
Man ska ju också veta att när man laddar upp inför en match så går man ju ofta genom en hel, ja men en uppladdning då eller vad man ska säga.
Man ska gå ner i virk och det är en ganska stor jävla process som man ska gå igenom.
Ja, ja men absolut.
Det vart ju inte så bra den här första matchen för att vi var ju tänkt att gå i Las Vegas där.
Det var väl bara någon dag innan vi åkte så så blev den första motståndaren skadad.
Vi fick en ny ganska snabbt som tog matchen med kort varsel bara en vecka innan.
Vi åker ner, landar, allting går som vanligt.
Vi tränar på plats, sköter viknergången bra.
Sen väl på fredag morgon så klipper vi de sista tre-fyra kilo.
Vi väger in och då kommer de fram och säger till oss att min motståndare har halkat tillbaka ut och slagit i huvudet.
Okej, va fan?
Vadå?
Okej, så jag har ingen makt i morgon.
Nej, tyvärr, vi vet inte vad vi ska göra.
Vi försöker leva en ersättare på 24 timmar.
Det går ju inte, vi kan inte hitta en ersättare på så kort tid.
Vi sa till Matchmakingvärld när vi stod vid invägenhet, att vi vet att vi har en galna nästa helg i New Jersey.
Försök att hitta någon där.
Och som tur var så krämslade, han jag skulle möta nu i New Jersey, Williams, hans motstånd där det drog sig djur samma dag.
Så han stod också utan.
Men han var ett ganska farligt gott möte.
Han var ganska mycket högre rankad än oss.
Men vi sa också att vi inte kan åka hit utan att ha gjort en match.
Så vi har gjort allt det här för att ge oss vad ni vill.
Vi tar 77 kilo, 87 kilo eller 80 kilo mellanvikt eller lätt tungvikt.
Kan vi också ta ge oss vad som helst.
Bara vi får match.
Så jag var ju beredd att gå upp till lätt tungvikt.
Men då fick jag ju den här Williams då.
Så då var vi ombokade den här helgen.
Så vi var kvar några dagar i Las Vegas, solade och badade och tränade.
Hur gör man det grejen?
Går du tillbaks och börjar käka för att få energi igen och sen gör du om?
Ja, det här var ju fredagen då som det var ta boken.
Så jag tog faktiskt och käkade ganska rejält på fredagkväll.
Käka lite gott bara för att få stämningen lite grann.
Och sen är vi bara drag igång och hålla sig i vikten till nästa fredag igen.
Och det är inte kul, det är jobbigt nog med ett weight cut.
Men det gick bra, jag hade en bra känsla.
Det var lite roligt för jag var sjuk under hela den tiden vi var borta.
Jag låg och hostade lungorna ur mig på nätterna.
Jag var riktigt förkyld, jag var orolig hela tiden att jag skulle dra på mig något typ av...
Låt som jättebra känsla.
Nej, kroppen kändes bra, men jag kände att jag är fan sjuk.
Så jag gick hela tiden orolig att jag skulle dra på mig någon form av hjärtmuskelreklamation eller någonting.
För jag tränade ganska hårt varje dag där också.
Men det gick bra, vi kom till New Jersey, checkade in, fortsatte träna och dieta.
Invägning på fredagen där, allting flöt på som det ska.
Sen på lördagen var det match.
Och så gick det bra?
Ja, jag kom in som andedog.
Alla trodde att han skulle vinna.
Men han hade inte en chans.
Så det gick jävligt bra.
Vad hände då när du vinner den här matchen?
Och när man slåss i UFC, vad är nästa steg?
Nu får du, du har väl x antal matcher som du har avtal på, men det är väl att man behöver fortsätta vinna lite grann för att det ska vara intressanta matcher.
Ja men så är det, absolut.
Det var ju lite såhär, kan man säga, både bra och dåligt att jag vann mot den här killen.
Du kom in i hetluften direkt.
Ja men precis, jag blir kastat i varje alla bräkt.
Istället för att ha fyra hyfsat lätta matcher på papper i det första kontraktet.
Men istället så spör jag någon som låg på 28e plats i världen.
Jag klev in på plats 100.
Så jag tog alls plats direkt i rankingen och ligger på 28e i världen nu.
Så nu får jag måta en som ligger på plats 20.
Ja men vad händer om jag vinner den här då?
Då kommer jag komma upp i topp 15 kanske.
På ett kontrakt som betalat pissdåligt.
Medan mina motståndare tjänar två miljoner på match så har jag ett lågt betalande kontraktlån där inne har varit contender ser vi.
Så vi får se lite grann hur det blir.
Det är klart att det är kul.
Men det hade kunnat vara bättre i ett ekonomiskt perspektiv om jag gjorde klart det första kontraktet.
Men mot lite sämre.
I MIMI finns det ingen UFC som är dålig.
Men om du förstår, lite sämre rankad.
Man smyger lite i bakgrunden först och sen går man in och börjar i takta.
Exakt, men jag hamnade liksom i toppen på en gång.
Men det är så där, det är bara att köra på.
Känner din familj samma lugn inför att du slåss?
Du sa ju att du skulle bli vuxen nu och bli farsan liksom.
Och så bara, nej men ja, det är klart jag ska in och slåss nu.
Det är roligt.
Jo, nej men alltså det är klart att det finns en stor oro och verbositet, främst hos min fru såklart.
Vi lever närmast varandra och vi har barn ihop.
Så hon går ju jämt med en oro, att det ska hända något och att man blir skamad, som kan påverka det privata nimet.
Det har jag full förståelse för, det är ju ingen lek det här.
Vill du att ditt barn ska slåss?
Nej, det vill jag inte, inte alls.
Han får börja triathlon eller?
Ja, nej men alltså vill han börja med kramsport så är det ju liksom bara brottning som gäller, känner jag.
På samma sätt som jag växte upp i min idrottsliga karriär, brottningen har ju format mig till den personen jag är idag.
Det är inte bara idrottsligt utan som person.
Så vill han göra det så är det brottning som gäller, inte någon annan kramsport.
En grej som jag tycker är lite spännande är att du bor ju lite off.
Du är ju inte direkt i Stockholm eller en dragklubb, utan du är ju lite norröver.
Hur får du dit?
Vi har ju haft ett par fighters från Sverige typ, men vi är ju ingen kampsports nation på det sättet.
Hur får du bra sparring och hur utvecklas du som fighter?
Hur har du lyckats hålla den utvecklingen igång?
Jag tror att jag skiljer mig ganska mycket från övriga eftersom jag är ganska duktig på att underhålla och sköta mig själv.
Många tror jag, om vi pratar om just den fysiska delen, den lever jag ganska mycket på.
Jag är ju den fighten som är extremt fysisk.
Jag sköter alltid min fysisk, min styrketräning, min konditionsträning och den gör jag helt och hållet hemma.
Sedan åker jag i veckorna till Västerås och min klubb där och sparras det jag behöver inför matcher.
Men den största delen sköter jag hemma.
Jag är nog den enda fighten i världen som inte kör så lite kampsport om man tänker på den här nivån.
Men det funkar för att jag har den disciplinen att vara hemma och sköta min träning.
Medan andra kanske blir lite såhär fan jag orkar inte riktigt träna.
Jag ligger hemma, jag har så mycket annat att göra.
Men det har vi liksom också mycket med att göra.
Jag har en kärlek till just träning.
All form av träning.
Jag älskar att träna.
Sen om det är simning, cykling, lökning, skidåkning.
Det spelar ingen roll.
Bara jag kan tumma min kropp och energi på något sätt.
Så jag kände mig nöjd.
Men det är nog det som får mig att kunna vara här i topp och ändå bo så långt bort.
Med brist på sparringpartners och så vidare.
Om du hade gått upp i nivå här, säga att nu vinner du och sen vinner du någon till.
Måste du byta livsstil då?
Jag vet inte riktigt, jag kommer nog inte byta livsstil.
Jag kommer inte flytta härifrån.
Det kommer jag inte.
Jag kanske måste lägga om träningen lite grann och få lite mer mängd i kampsport.
Och lite mindre fys.
Men inte för mycket, för jag vet att det jag gör funkar.
Det jag gör hemma här fungerar för att vara här på topp.
Jag försöker ju ändå vara, även om min tekniska bit inte är UFC-klass, så är min fysiska bit absolut där.
Så jag kan, även brottningen som jag har med mig från förut, så kan jag leva väldigt långt på just min musik och brottning.
Sen säger jag inte att jag har kastteknik i boksning och sånt, men den kan såklart bli bättre.
Det finns ju alltid en rädsla hos, möter man en duktig boksare och de möter en duktig brottare, så vågar ju inte de riktigt leva ut kanske, för att man vet att om man lever ut fullt ut och gör perfekt boksning, så kommer man typ bli nedtagen.
Absolut.
De måste ju anpassa sig, så det finns ju alltid en liten rädsla där.
Jaja det är så, jag mötte ju en boksare sist nu, i min senaste match.
Han var ju liksom känd på att vara en knockout-artist, och riktigt duktig boksning.
Men jag har en bra tränare som kan läsa lite grann och säga, det här ska du göra, så här ska du inte göra.
Han läste av att den här killen kan inte boksas, när han blir pressad, han kan inte boksas bakåt.
Det här är en striker som går framåt, kastar kombinationer när han är på väg framåt.
Så det du ska göra är att hålla höll press på honom och vara så nära som möjligt.
Så kommer du att slå ut hela hans boksning.
Det var det jag gjorde, det funkade perfekt.
Jag var nära han, det var snarare att jag fick bättre boksning än vad han lyckades åstadkomma.
För jag skickade han på hälarna hela tiden.
Den boksningen, den fantastiska boksaren som han var, såg vi inte skit av.
Hur funkar den relationen med tränaren?
Jag tänker, någonstans måste de ju vara, de måste ju trycka ner en lite samtidigt som när du ska avvakta i en vecka inför nästa match så måste de ju vara extremt supportive.
Hur länge har du jobbat med din tränare och hur funkar den dynamiken?
Nej men alltså, Jörgen Hambör heter han.
Han är lika mycket tränare som den.
Vi har en skitbra relation.
Det är klart att man tycker att han är pissbryg ibland.
Han tjatar att jag ska komma till Västerås och tränas på Arvinga och köra det och det men...
Han...
Jag tror han ändå har insett att jag är den individen jag är och kan sköta mig själv.
Men han är grym, han följer med på allt.
Han ställer upp för sina fighters, han brinner ju för det här.
Vi åker land och rike tillsammans.
Så den relationen måste ju vara bra.
Och det är det då.
Jag bara tänker, man spenderar ju fruktansvärt mycket tid i Ofos och så är det någon som hela tiden ska ligga på en och va...
Du gjorde fel här, här var också fel.
Bara så du vet så är detta också fel.
Ja men ibland vill man ju bara liksom, fan, dra åt helvete.
Men det är klart att det blir en frustration ibland.
Så är det ju, men det hör till.
Man landar ju alltid där i liksom att man...
Man måste fan lyssna på han ibland.
Likasam man måste ju lyssna på mig.
Jag känner ju mig själv bäst.
Ibland måste jag ju ändå ta till mig vad han tycker och tänker också.
För han är smak, han vet vad som behövs.
Det är ändå han som har hjälpt mig och tagit mig hit.
Jag förstår.
Andreas, stort stort stort tack för att vi fick snacka med dig.
Det är en jävla spännande resa.
Och stort lycka till när är nästa datum?
Det är 6 september.
Det är fan inte långt kvar.
Det är fyra veckor.
Det är då jag har min bröllopsfest.
Jag ska fråga min fru, vi har redan gift oss men nu har vi festen i Sverige, men jag ska fråga henne om det är okej att vi pausar av och streamar en stund där under bröllopsfesten.
Ja, men du kan ju sätta upp en sån här projekter.
Det blir perfekt igen.
Ja, det har jag fått ännu mer spö.
Exakt.
Stort tack för att du var med.
Ja, men tack.
Tack så mycket.
Vad ska man säga, din gameplan är, går du in och så håller du fast dem och så viskar du liksom i örat till dem att det är lugnt, jag är inte ens trött än.
Exakt, bara exakt vad jag gör.